foreign
another question from YouTube here Mel
has a question for us since my mother
discovered Amazon and Facebook ads she
has been filling our house to the brim
with stuff when I try to talk to her
about it she says it doesn't bother her
and tells me I'm mentally weak to let
things bother me I plan on going to grad
school soon and while I don't want to
take on student loan debt I'd feel
miserable if I continued to live at home
how can I keep the peace until I move
out well understanding that peace is not
acquired it is uncovered and
it sounds to me like her purchases are
covering up your piece but they're not
bothering her piece at all and so you
said I've tried to talk to her about it
but
maybe you don't need to talk to her
about it if she is not experiencing the
same sort of misery that you are this
doesn't sound like a her problem and I
know this isn't what you want to hear
because you were writing into the
minimalists and the minimalists should
have some sort of prescription to help
me tell my mother that she should let go
of the excess stuff in her life and I
have identified what is excess for her
but of course you can't identify what is
excess for someone else because what is
enough for me might be too much for you
what is too much for you might not be
enough for me and so
clutter is highly individual
and these things they might actually add
value to her life and she feels judged
and that's so she's coming back with a
judgment for you and I'm sorry to hear
that she's telling you that you're
mentally weak that's not the case here
it's a you have different preferences
you have a different idea of what adds
value to your life you have a different
understanding of what gets in the way
and right now while you're living under
the same roof
it seems like some of her things get in
the way now practically what can you do
you can have your own space in which
those things don't enter your space
that's a boundary that you set up for
yourself and then within the boundaries
there you can have your own rules you
download the minimalist rulebook it's 16
rules for living with less it's free
they're not actually rules though we
don't prescribe rules I do that because
everyone's looking for rules so we
called them rules but they're really
just tools they're boundaries you set up
within your own bounds but these aren't
rules to use to batter someone else with
your own preferences that's right
uh you are mentally weak for being
bothered by things that sounds like the
kind of thing that someone would say as
a defensive reaction to someone trying
to change their relationship to things
hey your things bother me you need to
get rid of them oh well you're mentally
weak for even being bothered by things
and I think the first step to get out of
that kind of scenario is to cease any
efforts to get that other person to
change their relationship to things for
your sake let them be who they are a
minimalist isn't someone who is
unbothered by things a minimum a
minimalist is someone who is
unencumbered by things a minimalist is
someone who is free to explore the
possibilities of life because they don't
have things weighing them down it was
Alan Watts who said um that the infinite
is not standoffish it's big enough to
include the finite I would say also that
the minimalist is not stand office but
the minimalist is flexible enough to
have room in his or her life for people
that love things right there's nothing
standoffish about minimalism and so I
would say you can keep the peace by
allowing her to be whoever and however
she needs to be and not trying to change
her and then you can say all right this
is an opportunity for me to practice the
real Beauty and power of my lifestyle
which is only revealed when you're in a
context where everybody doesn't have to
agree with you or be like you and you
don't it sounds like you don't have long
to wait sounds like grad school's around
the corner
um I say when my dad would say it's my
house it's my rules yeah drove me crazy
but he was right like it's his house it
says rules so you know um I wish I would
have taken this approach with my dad uh
rather than just being a rebellious
little jerk face but uh I wish I could
have went to my dad and I'm like you
know what you're right
um these are your rules
um here's what here's what I I feel like
I I need and this is this is what would
help me
um I don't know help me get along with
you better or help me uh live a live a
better life in this house or whatever it
is I wouldn't lay down for him like this
is what you got to do for me it would be
more like here's what I desire is there
any way for us to meet in the middle and
uh you know you could do this with your
mom in the sense of kind of what Josh
said like you probably have your own
space that where you can set up
boundaries is she Crossing those
boundaries if so well then have a
conversation with her and here's the
other thing too is like if you're
judging your mom or anybody if you're
going after them and saying you should
or you shouldn't or you know what you do
bothers me like that is going to create
um it's just going to create an argument
and it's a way to escalate the situation
and then they're going to look at you
and then they're going to give you an
insult back because they feel like uh
you know you've insulted them so rather
than finding a way to tell them what
they're doing wrong try to find a way to
tell them what they're doing right like
see how you can go out of your way to
just support their preferences I mean
I'm sure there's something you know
there's some good intention somewhere
with your mother so that's what I would
focus on is how can you support her with
the good intentions start there and then
maybe work into something that creates a
little bit more
uh I don't know a little a little or a
little less uh stress in your life did
you enjoy this Standalone patreon
highlight if so you can listen to full
episodes of the minimalists private
podcast available exclusively on patreon
visit patreon.com the minimalists or
click the link in the description your
support keeps our podcast and YouTube
Channel 100 advertisement free